j'ai souvent parlé de philosophie morale
sur cette chaîne est peut-être que les
arguments que j'ai présentées sur
certains sujets par exemple sur
l'éthique animale ont eu une influence
réelle sur le comportement de
quelques-uns d'entre vous après tout ce
serait bien la moindre des choses que la
philosophie morale contribuer à
l'amélioration moral de ceux qui s'y
intéressent
mais est ce vraiment le cas dans quelle
mesure des arguments philosophiques
froidement rationnelle peuvent-ils nous
pousser à l'action
ce type de questions un peu bizarre qui
relève davantage de la psychologique de
la philosophie en fait le philosophe et
psychologue
erich spitz geybels se penche dessus
depuis pas mal d'années et aujourd'hui
puisque je me suis bien entraînée à
prononcer son nom fit ce qu'ils veulent
je vais en profiter pour vous parler de
quelques unes des études qui l'a mené
sur ce sujet et notamment sa toute
dernière dont il vient de présenter les
résultats préliminaires il ya quelques
semaines vous verrez que la méthode est
assez drôle et ingénieuse puisque ça
consistait notamment à organiser un
grand concours d'arguments philosophique
pour savoir qui a la plus grosse taille
des faits et on verra si peter singer
champion de la philosophie morale
contemporaine s'il en est mérite bien
son titre de champion at il le meilleur
argument pour nous rendre meilleurs
hé hé oui valentine et j'ai un truc à
dire justement tu vois pas qui fait le
montage mais c'est très meta mais on
espère pour l'interrompre
sap avait des cailloux alléchés par mois
ci s'il ya bien un groupe qui
s'entraînent à réfléchir à des questions
éthiques difficile et des dilemmes
moraux tordu ça pourrait être vous chers
abonnés mais ce sont plus encore les
spécialistes de philosophie morale eux
mêmes les eti cistes comme on dit dans
le monde anglo saxon c'est à dire les
gens comme tidiane a beau nier en somme
et donc l'idée sous jacente des
premières études de schwyz gamble pour
mettre en évidence l'influencé de la
philosophie morale sur le comportement
était que si une telle influence exister
on pourrait s'attendre à ce qu'elle soit
particulièrement forte sur ces eti
cistes surexposés à la philosophie
morale qui devrait donc se comporter
mieux en moyenne ou en tout cas
différemment que des groupes similaires
moins exposé à la philosophie morale
pour étudier cela est riche fils bebel
et je sois reste on fait passer des
questionnaires à presque 6 ans
professeur d'université aux etats unis
parmi lesquels des spécialistes de
philosophie morale mais aussi des
philosophes d'autres spécialités et
enfin des professeurs d'autres
disciplines qui servait de groupe
contrôle le questionnaire contenait
d'abord des questions normatives où il
s'agissait de porter des jugements
moreau sur tel ou tel type d'actions par
exemple sur une échelle de 1 le pire à
neuf le meilleur 5 étant moralement
neutre où placez-vous le fait de donner
régulièrement son sens et il avait
ensuite des questions qui leur demandait
de rapporter leur propre comportement
par exemple combien de fois par
randonnée vous votre sang ou encore
quelle est la dernière fois vous avez
donné votre sens donc les jugements d'un
côté les actes de l'autre vous voyez
l'idée
ce questionnaire permettait ainsi de
détecter dans quelle mesure il y à des
variations dans le degré d'adhésion à
diverses normes morales selon les
différents groupes et aussi dans quelle
mesure il y a des différences dans les
comportements qu'ils rapportent
et donc s'il ya bien une cohérence entre
les normes morales et les actes au sens
où plus d'un groupe adhère à une norme
plus on s'attend à ce que le
comportement correspondant il soit
fréquemment rapportés et qu'elles ont
donc été les résultats de cette étude
à votre avis les spécialistes de
philosophie morale sont ils des
parangons de vertu et bien sûr certaines
questions ces spécialistes semblait
adhérer à des normes morales plus
exigeantes en effet par exemple 84%
d'entre eux jugeaient le fait de donner
régulièrement son sens comme plutôt bien
là où il n'était que 72 % chez les non
philosophes ou encore concernant le fait
de ne pas indiquer sur son permis de
conduire que l'on consent don d'organes
60% des spécialistes de philosophie
morale considérer que c'est plutôt mal
contre 42 % dans le groupe des non
philosophe donc ça fait là des
différences assez nette dans leurs
jugements moraux en effet mais ce qu'on
veut vraiment savoir c'est si ces
jugements se traduisent bien en actes et
sur ce point cette étude semble montrer
que non quand on se penche sur les
comportements rapporté on n'observe pas
de différence entre les spécialistes de
philosophie morale et les autres groupes
il est en gros aussi peu de donneurs de
sang et autant de personnes indiquant
sur leur permis de conduire qu'elles
consentent au don d'organes que ce soit
dans le groupe des spécialistes
philosophie morale chez les philosophes
nos spécialistes ou chez les professeurs
d'autres spécialités et il en allait de
même sur à peu près toutes les questions
morales testé dans cette étude ont
trouvé parfois un degré d'adhésion plus
fort à une en morale chez spécialiste de
philosophie morale et dans une moindre
mesure chez les autres philosophes sans
que cela se traduise nettement au niveau
du comportement
ces résultats sont assez surprenants ou
peut-être pas si surprenant que ça hein
tout dépend de l'opinion vous aviez des
professeurs de philosophie morale au
départ moi c'est juste des gens qui se
cherchent des bonnes raisons pour
écraser tout le monde avec un tramway
quoi
massy notons que cette étude de 2014 a
été répliquée par une autre équipe en
2018 sur 1500 professeurs germanophone
cette fois et c'est intéressant car
applications et eu lieu dans un contexte
culturel et philosophique assez
différente l'influencent de quand
beaucoup plus importante en allemagne
sera t-elle bénéfique
et bien non globalement ils ont trouvé
les mêmes résultats à savoir quelques
différences entre les groupes dans leurs
jugements moraux avec des spécialistes
de philosophie morale plus exigeants
moralement mais pas ou très peu de
différences dans les comportements
rapporté donc tout ça semble plutôt
solide
il ya seulement une question ou l'étude
répliqué n'a pas donné le même résultat
celle du végétarisme et il se trouve que
cette question là un statut assez
particulier dans les deux études donc ça
mérite qu'on s'y arrête un moment
ah bah justement parlant de végétarisme
non mais je fais le montage là et puis
on parle guitariste phil jones
bravo merci il se trouve que dans
l'étude de ce fils bebel déjà le cas du
végétarisme était assez particulier
parce que c'est le seul sujet sur lequel
les différences normative entre les
groupes étaient vraiment très très très
élevé mangez régulièrement de la viande
de mammifères comme le boeuf le porc
était jugée comme plutôt mal par 60% des
spécialistes de philosophie morale 45%
des philosophes nos spécialistes et
seulement 19% des noms philosophe
l'écart normatif et énorme du simple au
triple or à la question de savoir si de
fait les participants ont mangé du boeuf
du porc à leur dernier repas les écarts
étaient beaucoup beaucoup un grand 45%
des philosophes répondait oui mais il en
allait de même pour 37% des spécialistes
de philosophie morale un peu mieux donc
mais ce n'est pas très net
et ça ne reflète pas du tout l'énorme
écart normatif entre les deux groupes
en fait on pourrait même se servir de
ces résultats pour soutenir que les
philosophes sont plus condamnable
moralement en ceci qu'ils ont moins
d'excusés ils sont bien davantage
convaincu que c'est mal mais ne le font
pas tellement moins que les autres et
voilà faites ce que je dis pas ce que je
fais tes jambes on met donc dans l'étude
répliqué en 2018 sur les professeurs
allemands les choses sont assez
différentes
déjà sur le plan normatif 67% des
spécialistes de philosophie morale et
61% des philosophes nos spécialistes
sont convaincus que manger régulièrement
viande est plutôt condamnable moralement
donc ce serait devenue une position
majoritaire chez les philosophes en
général et pas seulement chez les
spécialistes de philosophie morale et du
côté des professeurs d'autres
disciplines ce sont 39 % d'entre eux qui
partagent cette même opinion donc
l'écart est toujours nette par rapport
aux philosophes mais l'opinion est quand
même deux fois plus répandu que dans la
première étude où le chiffre était de
19%
mais là où c'est intéressant surtout
c'est sur la question du comportement
dans l'étude répliqué 40% des nos
philosophes rapporte ne pas avoir mangé
de viande de boeuf ou de porc à leur
dernier repas alors c'était 45 % dans la
première étude donc c'est assez proche
malgré la grosse progression dans
l'adhésion à la norme morale
par contre pour les spécialistes de
philosophie morale c'est descendu à 24 %
contre 37 pour cent dans la première
étude
finalement là sur ce sujet en
particulier la philosophie morale semble
avoir fini par produire un effet notable
et de façon intéressante on ne retrouve
pas cet effet chez les philosophes non
spécialistes qui sont à peu près aussi
nombreux que les nouveaux philosophes à
avoir mangé de la viande alors le
dernier repas ce serait bien spécifique
au spécialiste de philosophie morale
mais bon ça reste vraiment un cas unique
dans ses études et pour tout le reste
qu'on peut en retenir encore une fois
c'est que même quand les normes morales
sont plus exigeantes chez les
spécialistes de philosophie morale les
comportements rapportés sont à peu près
les mêmes bon alors on peut conclure que
ça sert à peu près à rien la philosophie
morale c'est bon c'est réglé car si je
peux me permettre justement à ce propos
eh bien non erich spitz belle n'avait
pas l'intention de s'arrêter là ok eh
bien non eric je suis belle n'avait pas
l'intention de s'arrêter là une autre
chose qui l'intéressait c'était de
savoir si en présentant un argument de
philosophie morale un nom philosophe on
peut contribuer à modifier son
comportement moral la froide raison du
philosophe peut-elle suffire à motiver
l'action en 2018
erich spitz bebel et chris mc veigh ont
mené l'étude suivante pour essayer de le
mettre en évidence les participants
étaient répartis aléatoirement dans
quatre groupes le premier groupe devait
lire un argument philosophique concluant
à l'obligation morale de donner au moins
une part modeste de ses revenus à des
organismes de charité
ce genre d'arguments très classique on
retrouve chez peter singer du type
arguments de l'enfant qui se noie pour
ceux qui connaissent le second groupe
devait lire un témoignage émouvant d'une
famille sauver de l' esclavage par
organisme de charité le troisième groupe
de vie lire les deux textes et enfin le
dernier groupe le groupe contrôle devait
lire un extrait d'un manuel scolaire qui
n'avait aucun rapport avec tout ça à
l'issue de la lecture chaque participant
est informé qu'il aura une chance sur
dix de gagner 10 dollars après le
questionnaire et avant le tirage au sort
chaque participant doit décider au cas
où il recevrait ses 10 dollars quelle
part il souhaitant reversée à un
organisme de charité de son choix
le participant peut choisir de ne rien
donner de donner une partie seulement ou
de donner la totalité des 10 $ qu'il
pourrait gagner
l'intérêt de ce dispositif déjà c'est
que c'est contrôlé randomisé évidemment
et sait aussi qu'on va pouvoir étudier
un comportement réel et non pas un
comportement rapporté comme dans les
études les spécialistes de philosophie
morale demander aux gens de rapporter un
comportement c'est pas aussi fiable qu
observer directement un comportement là
le choix que fait le participant aux
cours du questionnaire et bien
équivalent à faire un don au moins dont
potentiel à un organisme de charité
et donc si l'argument philosophique à la
singer qui conclut à l'obligation morale
de faire de tels dons à bien un effet
sur le comportement ou pourrait
s'attendre à ce que les participants qui
ont lui l'argument donne sensiblement
plus en moyenne que les participants du
groupe contrôle et non le groupe qui n'a
lu que l'argument philosophique a donné
approximativement autant que le groupe
contrôle
honnêtement une petite partie de moi
s'attendait presque qu'ils donnent moins
en fait une sorte de réaction rejet face
à la philosophie morale
par contre le groupe qui a lu le
témoignage émouvant a bien donné
sensiblement plus en moyenne est de même
pour le groupe qui a lu les deux textes
il a donné à peu près autant que le
groupe qui a lu seulement le témoignage
donc c'est avant tout le témoignage
émouvant qui a eu un effet sur le
comportement
mais l'argument philosophique en faveur
du don qu'il était du seul ou accompagné
du témoignage ne semble avoir eu presque
aucun effet sur les dons des
participants
coup dur pour la philosophie morale un
coup dur mais bon peut-être que le
problème vient de l'argument
philosophique utilisée dans l'étude
peut-être qu'il ne sait pas très
convaincant en fin de compte pas assez
grand public
peut-être que les philosophes peuvent
faire mieux quand même ami philosophe ne
nous décourageons pas eric schmidt
kebbel et fieri kochman ont annoncé en
2019 qu'il relancerait une étude
similaire en demandant cette fois au
philosophe de concocter leurs meilleurs
arguments pour convaincre les
participants de donner ses 10 dollars
concrètement ils ont organisé un grand
concours d'arguments philosophique dans
le gagnant déterminé par les résultats
de l'étude
ce ver est récompensé de 1000 $ dont au
moins 500 $ 2
est reversée à un organisme de charité
et je me dis que c'est quand même
dommage de pas avoir demandé à chaque
participant qui propose un argument au
concours d'annoncer lui-même à l'avance
la part de la récompense qu'il souhaite
reverser un organisme de charité
ça aurait fait une étude dans l'étude
c'est très métal si j'ose dire en
quelque sorte en outre du reste
nonobstant le règlement du concours
spécifiait une longueur maximale et
quels types d'arguments on pouvait
utiliser en proscrivant notamment le
simple appel à l'émotion ce terrible est
que schumann ont reçu une centaine de
propositions et n'ayant pas les moyens
de les tester tout ils en ont
sélectionné manuellement une vingtaine
en privilégiant une variété d'approchés
de style philosophique et ils les ont
testés selon la même méthode que l'étude
précédente c'est à dire que les
participants lisez l'un de ses arguments
puis été informés qu'ils avaient une
chance sur dix de recevoir 10 $ et
devait choisir quelle part de ces 10
dollars il donnerait un organisme de
charité de leur choix la première phase
du test sur 20 arguments avec 2500
participants donc environ 120
participants par argument leur a permis
de sélectionner les cinq arguments qui
avaient obtenu les meilleurs résultats
et qui semblait donc les plus
prometteurs et ils ont mené l'étude
finale sur ces cinq arguments seulement
le groupe contrôle dans cette phase
finale était constitué de 471
participants et chacun des autres
groupes testés comptait environ 335
participants et cette fois enfin chaque
groupe exposé à l'un de ses cinq
arguments philosophiques à donne est
sensiblement plus que le groupe contrôle
les participants du groupe contrôle
donne est en moyenne de dollars 50 et
ceux des autres groupes donnaient en
moyenne autour de 3 dollars 50 avec en
particulier un trio de tête qui frôle
les 4 dollars
donc l'effet est bien là de l'ordre de
40% d'augmentation de dons c'est pas
négligeable alors à ce stade vous vous
demandez sans doute à quoi ressemblent
ces fameux meilleurs arguments
vous pouvez trouver les 5 finalistes sur
le billet de blog dont je vous mets le
lien dans la description est notée pour
ma part j'ai une petite préférence pour
l'argument numéro 5 qui est très dans
mon style avec une expérience de pensée
à base de gros bouton sur lequel on a
cuit pour augmenter la probabilité
qu'une personne attrape la malaria
mais vous avez sûrement envie de savoir
surtout qu'elle était l'argument
vainqueur celui qui a remporté le
concours et bien roulement de tambour
cet argument victorieux ça ne s'invente
pas c'est celui qui avait proposé
peter singer
et matthew lynn dehors donc singer reste
bien le boss final de la philosophie
morale
y'a pas à dire il me semble intéressant
de noter que peter singer comme j'en
parlais dans cet épisode est l'un des
piliers de l'altruisme efficace un
mouvement qui vise à promouvoir un
altruisme fondée sur les preuves en
quelque sorte pour établir quelles
actions produits c'est un maximum
d'effets bénéfiques et donc singer bien
plus que premiers philosophes venus a le
souci de donner des arguments efficace
auprès du grand public quand il
s'exprime pour le grand public
typiquement dans ses livres qui
promeuvent l'altruisme efficace comme de
moscou du can do traduit en français
sous le titre
l'altruisme efficace il a forcément
beaucoup plus d'expérience en la matière
que les autres philosophes qui auront eu
plutôt l'habitude de s'exprimer avant
tout pour leur père et je vous êtes un
peu familier avec l'âge truisme efficace
vous allez voir que l'argument de singer
dont le concours développe un cas très
classique qu'on retrouve très souvent
dans les présentations sur le sujet bref
on sent qu'il a du métier le peter alors
ce fameux argument venons y aura quand
même le lire en plus il est plutôt très
courts et tu connais l'histoire des deux
seuls stades qui entre dans un bar et je
leurs arguments de deux seniors sinon de
nombreuses personnes dans les pays
pauvres souffrent d'une maladie appelée
trachome le trachome est la principale
cause de cécité évitable dans le monde
le trachome se développe à partir de
bactéries qui pénètre dans les yeux des
enfants en particulier des enfants qui
vivent dans des environnements chauds et
poussiéreux où l'hygiène est mauvaise
s'il n'est pas traité un enfant atteint
de trachome commencera à souffrir d'une
vision trouble et deviendra
progressivement aveugle
même si cela peut prendre de nombreuses
années il existe un traitement très bon
marché qui permet de guérir la maladie
avant que la cécité ne se développent un
don aussi modeste que 25 dollars versés
à un organisme efficace peut éviter à
une personne de devenir aveugle plus
tard dans sa vie
combien payez-vous pour éviter que votre
propre enfant ne deviennent aveugles
la plupart d'entre nous payerait 25000
dollars 250 mille dollars voire plus si
nous en avions les moyens la souffrance
des enfants dans les pays pauvres doit
d'apporter plus qu'un millième deux fois
autant que la souffrance de notre propre
enfant c'est pourquoi il est bon de
soutenir l'un des organismes efficace
qui préviennent la cécité duo trachome
et qui ont besoin de plus de dons pour
atteindre plus de personnes
et c'est tout donc en gros l'argument
consiste d'une part à informer d'une
situation concrète ou un don modeste
peut avoir un effet important sur la
qualité de vie futur dans l'enfant dans
un pays pauvre de souligner que nous
sommes prêts à dépenser mille fois plus
pour notre propre enfant qui ferait face
aux mêmes risques et qui me semble pas
que la souffrance d'un enfant pauvre
dans un pays éloigné soit 1000 fois
moins importante moralement c'est
vraiment très très très simple pas
d'expérience de penser sophistiqué pas
de long et multiples raisonnement pas de
pistolet sur la tempe
juste la présentation d'une situation
concrète et le rappel d'une norme à
laquelle quasi tout le monde adhère et
dont il suit que face à cette situation
concrète nous aurions l'obligation de
donner c'est très simple et c'est
peut-être ça qui fait que c'est efficace
alors vous pourriez objecter que ça joue
en partie sur une dimension émotionnelle
en évoquant notre propre enfant mais ça
fait d'une façon qui reste assez factuel
et comptable ça ne dit pas imaginer
votre propre enfant soit atteint comme
vous seriez désespéré etc sadi seulement
considérer calcium vous seriez prêt à
dépenser pour la santé de votre enfant
et puis globalement tous les arguments
sur ce type de sujets ont une dimension
émotionnelle vu qu'on doit parler de
souffrance de maladie de pauvreté etc
le règlement du concours ils exigeaient
seulement de ne pas tomber dans le
simple appel à l'émotion proprement dit
et il me semble que l'argument de singer
satisfait bien cette condition en tout
cas d'une façon comparable à la plupart
des autres arguments en compétition donc
voilà bravo à singer et l'hymne de
heurts qui ont vaillamment remporté ce
concours
bravo félicitations je vais leur faire
un bravo bravo bravo vous pourriez aussi
vouloir tempérer ses félicitations par
ceux ci que c'est d'une très courte tête
qu il le remporte
mais déjà il faut noter que leurs mêmes
arguments étaient aussi arrivés en tête
lors de la première phase de test qui
opposait 20 arguments donc soit ils ont
eu deux fois de la chance mais c'est un
peu surprenant soit leur argument est
bien le plus efficace de ce groupe
en outre et c'est surtout ce point qui
me semblent intéressants les
participants devaient après l'heure donc
répondre à quelques questions concernant
leur attitude vis-à-vis de l'argument
qu'ils avaient lu par exemple à quel
point ils l'ont trouvé convaincant et
s'ils pensent que la voir lui a eu pour
effet qu'ils ont donné davantage
et sur ces questions là l'argument de
singer l'emportent largement sur tous
les autres
il semble donc que ce soit l'argument
qui non seulement à
plus influencer le comportement des
participants mais aussi qui est le plus
reconnu par les participants eux-mêmes
comme ayant influencé leur comportement
enfin voilà qu'est ce que vous pensez de
tout ça alors pourquoi l'argument de
singer est il le plus efficace et
pensez-vous que vous auriez pu proposer
vous même à l'argument encore plus
efficace pour motiver le don vous pensez
pouvoir battre singer à ce jeu lancé
vous un commentaire si vous voulez c'est
juste pour le référencement il n'est pas
du tout abonné vous n'oubliez pas la
cloche
reste à la cloche sinon tu es bien enfin
m'écoutais je pourrais peut-être savoir
qu'il ya une étude qui vient de sortir
the singer oui je sais je vais en parler
là tout de suite on se calme c'est eric
tu me mann's planes c'est parce que je
suis une femme que tu me coupe
cette vidéo est déjà d'une longueur
respectable mais juste au moment où je
finissais décrire ce script florian kova
qui m'a fait l'honneur de le relire m'a
signalé la publication récente d'un
article signé notamment par matthew lynn
deux heures et peter singer donc nos
deux auteurs de l'argument victorieux et
cet article porte exactement sur ce
sujet de cette vidéo donc faut quand
même que j'en dise un mot c'est en fait
une étude très similaire à la première
de schwitzguébel qui comparé l'effet
d'un argument rationnel à celui d'un
témoignage émouvant
cette première étude je le rappelle
avait conclu à l'inefficacité de
l'argument rationnelle par rapport aux
témoignages pour augmenter les doses le
dispositif de l'étude de lindauer et
singer est quasiment le même les
participants sont informés qu'il
pourrait gagner 100 dollars suite à un
tirage au sort à la fin du questionnaire
et ils peuvent choisir de donner une
part de ces 100 $ à un organisme de
charité efficace pour lutter contre la
pauvreté
avant cela les participants sont
exposées soit à un appel à l'émotion
avec le nom et la photo d'un enfant qui
a été aidé par un tel organisme soit un
argument rationnel qui d'ailleurs assez
différent de celui qui a remporté le
concours de ce fils geybels et plus
froid plus long avec même un argument
évolutionnaire au milieu ou alors les
participants pouvaient être exposés à
une combinaison des deux dans un ordre
ou dans l'autre ordre et enfin il y
avait un groupe contrôle qui n'était
exposée à rien du tout et voici le
tableau qui résume les principaux
résultats de l'étude
vous voyez que les participants du
groupe contrôle ont en moyenne donné
nettement moins que les participants de
tous les autres groupes et de façon
intéressante
l'argument rationnelle suivi de l'appel
à l'émotion aurais tu un effet plus fort
tandis que dans l'ordre inverse
les faits semblent similaires à celui de
l'argument seul ou de là
l'émotion seul il semble qu'il vaille
mieux raisonner puis émouvoir
qu'émouvoir puis raisonnée c'est bon à
savoir
alors évidemment ce n'est jamais qu'une
étude et il faut que ce type de résultat
soit encore consolidée par d'autres mais
ça fait d'un deuxième élément assez
probant en faveur d'une efficacité d'au
moins certains arguments philosophiques
pour motiver un comportement altruiste
de dons tu vois j'en ai parlé je
souhaite pas complètement autre chose
mais mais c'était très intéressant mais
alors ça suffit
la blague ce jeu là que ça vient de deux
minutes et c'est sérieux si c'est une
chaîne de philo mais en fait je veux les
inquiétudes de chouf flip voilà lui et
et singer qui est sortie et ça rentre
pas là-dedans trentaine donc c'est un
peu qu'on ne veut pas en parler tu vois
bon c'est vrai ouais bon ouais ouais
j'avoue bref fois que j'en parle
faut que je fasse un passage du coup
comme si ce n'était pas déjà assez long
[ __ ] ça me saoule mais je peux m'en
occuper moi si tu veux j'aime beaucoup
les philosophes et bergson aussi donc ça
va être cool
[Musique]
cette nouvelle étude réunit rien de
moins que les précédents militer c'est
quoi oui non non non monsieur fille
vient fortuitement de prendre
connaissance de nouvelles études qui
vient de sortir et qui réunit les non
moins fameux schlitz plus speed keable
lui et et singer et qui portent
exactement sur le sujet de cette vidéo
donc ça tombe plutôt bien comme quoi
c'est un sujet très discuté en ce moment
c'est chaud l'idée de l'étude c'était
sur une cohorte de plus de 1000
étudiants en philosophie dont une moitié
suivait un cours sur l'éthique animale
et l'autre moitié suivait un cours sur
l'éthique des dons aux organismes de
charité et de comparer ensuite
l'évolution des achats de ses étudiants
dans des restaurants universitaires
est ce que ceux qui avaient suivi le
cours sur l'éthique animale mangeait
plus ou moins de viande que les autres
plus il serait assez contre intuitif tu
vois le suspense est insoutenable
schwyz flou et goebbels les débits des
vues et des convaincus que ça marcherait
pas et ben en fait ça un peu marcher
avant pour les étudiants des deux
groupes acheté en moyenne 50 2% de plats
à base de viande ça restait stable après
le court pour les étudiants qui avaient
suivi le cours sur les types de la
charité par contre pour l'autre groupe
il ya une diminution de nombre de plats
contenant de la viande on est passé de
52 % à 45 % quand même pas pas dégueu
quoi mais c'est pas fichu non plus comme
on dit dans le jargon
après comme on a vu plus tôt le cas du
végétarisme semble quand même assez
particulier je pense que c'est l'un des
comportements les plus influençables par
la philosophie morale
aujourd'hui ça aurait été intéressant de
voir si on pouvait trouver un effet
similaire sur le comportement de don
après un cours sur l'éthique du don par
exemple et pour le coup je serai moins
confiants depuis vaincu en soi quand on
étudie comme ça l'effet d'un cours de
philosophie morale c'est très difficile
de savoir exactement ce qui dans le
court a vraiment eu de l'influencé sur
comportement parce que c'est pas
forcément les arguments philosophiques
eux mêmes qui ont eu un impact sur le
comportement
donc bon voilà c'est intéressant mais
faut pas non plus s'emballer tu veux
faire mon épisode à ma place ou
enfin pour conclure sur tout ça et pour
donner quand même un peu mon avis sur la
question de savoir dans quelle mesure la
philosophie morale peut améliorer le
comportement moral et je souligne que ce
que je vais donner maintenant ce n'est
que mon avis suite à la lecture de tout
ça j'ai tendance à penser tout de même
que les arguments de philosophie morale
n'ont généralement qu'une influence très
limitée sur le comportement mais qu'il y
à quelques exceptions notamment chez les
altruistes efficace dont la plupart des
fondateurs et des représentants les plus
notables sont des philosophes d'ailleurs
en effet de façon évidente le
comportement des altruistes efficace
semble très très largement influencée
par des conceptions de philosophie
morale c'est un peu le principe même du
mouvement pour ainsi dire mais bon les
altruistes efficace ça reste un type de
cas plutôt exceptionnel et même en les
approuvant moralement ce sont des cas
que la plupart d'entre nous n'avons je
crois pas réellement envie d'imiter en
fait et si j ça c'est que ça rejoint un
sujet qu eric fils gueule on revient à
lui avait étudié dans un article
intitulé gaming forme orale médiocrité
il y défend la thèse selon laquelle la
plupart des gens vise seulement la
moyenne moral c'est-à-dire ne pas être
bien pire mais aussi ne pas être bien
meilleur moralement que leur terre et
sait pas si évident comme thèse on
pourrait penser au contraire que tout le
monde vise l'excellence moral et que si
tout le monde ne l'atteint pas et se
situe plutôt dans la moyenne c'est
seulement parce que tout le monde n'est
pas capable de mieux
un peu comme dans une course où tout le
monde veut faire le meilleur temps mais
où la plupart des coureurs font un temps
moyen faute d'être capable de mieux dans
une course il ya toujours un peloton qui
se forment mais on ne veut pas être dans
le peloton si on peut faire mieux
évidemment
et bien la thèse de schwyz goebbels et
qu'en matière de morale on n'est pas
dans le peloton moral malgré soi la
plupart des gens veulent être dans le
peloton et non faire la course en tête
dans ce doc des médiocres moralement ça
va c'est toi qui médiocre d'abord ses
six fils gamble a raison sur ce point ça
pourrait expliquer en partie les
résultats qu'on a vu sur l'inefficacité
de la philosophie morale
les seules personnes dont le
comportement est susceptible d'être
sensiblement améliorée par la
philosophie morale ce serait celle qui
vise effectivement l'excellence morale
et non la moyenne or ces personnes
seraient en fait plutôt rare
probablement aussi rare chez les
spécialistes
immoral qu'ailleurs en somme la
philosophie morale peut sans doute nous
informer sur ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour mieux se comporter pour se tirer
moralement vers le haut mais en matière
de morale il serait en fait rare d'être
motivé à faire plus que ce qui suffit à
nous ranger dans le peloton morale suite
des choux seoul 22 petits sadique là
abonnez vous ses fesses du tissage est
plus fin ma fille ni sa fille ne sais
pas si j'y vois là pour cet épisode
plein d'eric schmidt kebbel et de
psychologie et aussi de valentine de
science de comptoir qui l'aurait
remarqué là j'espère que ça vous a plu
si tel est le cas vous pouvez le
manifester comme il vous plaira
un très très grand merci à toutes celles
et ceux qui me soutiennent sur tipi ou
sur youtube
on se revoit bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo en attendant portez vous bien et à
défaut d'être excellent tâcher d'être au
moins moralement moyens cailloux